today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block pizza is in
Los Angeles at 1811 Pico Boulevard on
the way to the beach gray block get that
hitter today's guest is a man that I've
wanted to come in for probably about a
year I guess and he is you know I'm from
last chance you he's quite a polarizing
figure
I mean if he were in the will um if he
were in the wilder Ness he would be a
polarizing bear he's also the author of
hate me now and love me later
it's a new book you can get it on Amazon
ladies and gentlemen coach Jason Brown
[Music]
what's up slap dicks man that's probably
my favorite yeah cuz I grew up man we
had a coach man and he would always call
us numbnuts all the time like you
jackasses but get you dick out each
others butts and get out here
that's what he'd say he'd come in the
locker room and say that coach Jason
Brown nice to see you today man I
appreciate you having me yeah it's an
honor man it's a pleasure man I'm hot
off the second season of y'all show so
good deal I haven't watched it yet man
haven't watched the first one really
yeah I've seen bits and pieces here and
there but not you close just har let's
get a little closer gotcha yeah yeah
don't be afraid to eat it like this
okay got it right up on it okay yeah how
many of the players like our I mean how
much coaching are you able to do at the
JUCO level and how much it is of it is
just like like sheep herding just guys
who are just real just [ __ ] good
question man a lot of people don't ask
that question they don't realize what
just Muppets but I'm sure you get some
Muppets at that level ground Muppets so
I know what it's like to be around them
no doubt you don't coach a lot man
people don't realize I can coach
remember in the country and now they'll
tell you the d1 guys that know me you
know I grew up I got my name as a coach
X's and O's a lot of people stole things
from me offensively I won't get into
that but became a once you get the head
job which I've had a few of them you
become a manager now and in Kansas at
independence man I didn't have the
opportunity to hire enough as a
coordinator because we did have the
resources so since that was my baby I
said you know what screw it I'll run the
Oh higher spend more money on defensive
side or hiring off it's a lion coach so
I did those things where you compare
that to Buddy Stevens first year or two
years on the show he didn't do much of
any coaching at all
he managed as well and he had that thing
rolling I was in the process of building
like he did hmm he's been there ten plus
years I was there year Warren starting
this program so I said let me take the
offense he's got the resource
builds up to where he can hire some
coaches and Pam incident was the reason
why I suddenly like some of that the
finances wasn't there we did just
weren't ever there what we got going
there shoot man the money that we raised
me and my boss Tammy we came up with a
lot of money to get some decent coaches
that we could get but we still had shoot
so average about 15 to 17 coaches a year
more than anybody in JUCO and probably
hit eight of them run paid so they were
guys that were were that I gutted and
worked hard but shoot 17 of them got d1
jobs too in three years Wow yeah so hate
me now love me later yeah
look man well that's the book right
that's the book the book man I
appreciate this copy no doubt but how
much of it like when you get a lot of
these players because at that level it's
a lot of players that have already had a
first and second chance kind of or or is
that not the cases is is it a lot of
guys who you're able to go and get them
right out of high school and bring them
in directly so I get three types of kids
okay alright so one is the high school
non qualifier he didn't qualify out of
high school he was a division 1 prospect
yeah didn't have the grades I go get
those kids best of the best of those
kids the second type of kid is a d1 kid
that went to the 4-year so went to
Alabama went to Georgia wherever and
flunked out smoked weed got kicked out
had some type of charge and they're
already at these universities I'm sorry
going the third ones to them no and then
the third one is the kid that's at the
d1 as well who's a good kid good grades
does everything right isn't playing the
amount of time he wants to play and says
you know what screw it
I want a shot to go get re recruited
comes to me and that's a jonathan banks
that played at Tulane or he was at
Kansas State actually so came from
Kansas State to me back to Tulane yeah
so those are what we call for to for
kids for they were at a four year came
to a two-year it went back to a four
year okay so we get a lot of those so
they're coming down to get the tape to
get the field to get the stats and then
go back up to it another place where
they can start work immediately
yeah and I've had shoot you know that's
year alone we had 28 d1 transfers and
you know nobody in the country has that
but only eight of them played so usually
you think about it a lot of those kids
are broken they're far far they're
probably we call
damaged goods so can i the d1 coach that
sends me those kids because you're
hurting the sheep but some of the some
of the sheep have like prison turn oh oh
yeah no like damn the sheep's tattered
uh no no doubt and I got it yeah and I
got a [ __ ] massage them try to make V
a lot of lamp
you know that's wild chicken salad
chicken [ __ ] but you know we get it
going man we we you know the d1 coach
sends me the kid yeah over most coaches
because the fact they know my reputation
precedes itself as far as when my kid
leaves me he don't [ __ ] up at the next
level really he don't get kicked out so
222 kids which I'm most proud of didn't
Division one in my coaching career never
had a kid get kicked out of a four-year
or go to jail
I mean that left me that left you and
went to a four-year no never is that you
don't see a lot of that on the show I
know they don't I know they don't show a
lot of that stuff they don't really with
101 kids signed scholarships in three
years there which is you know nothing
close to that and they don't show that
really don't show all the names it's a
put in perspective the first year show
last year when we want it five kids they
showcase Amite good and right keen Boyd
Malik Henry hmm Bobby Bruce yeah
they don't show the other forty kids at
signed Division one there's 40 kids on
d1 a year I see you know so we so yeah
you're only getting a taste in is that
because they only chose those kids to do
the kids kind of like do an initial
interview and then they're like okay
these are the ones that we want to focus
on they do they spend tons of time early
on trying to find who their guys are
gonna be the storyline and so you know
it's unfortunate like Jermaine Johnson
this year said Georgia yeah yeah number
one play in the country
koi dang the number two player in the
country who's at Cal we had both of them
so and you never even saw Chloe you
didn't see him at all so is it because
they didn't [ __ ] rob McDonald's or is
it they didn't have the broken life that
a lot of the other ones did who knows
right they kind of stayed out the
limelight they just did their business
handled it and got on but you know we
sent a kid to Cal Berkeley koi tang Wow
when we sent a kid to Vanderbilt in the
same season last year kid named Dante
Carrie Williams that's never happened to
you
send the kid to Vanderbilt and Cal the
reason I say that is I don't know if you
know Cal Berkeley and Vanderbilt are
probably two highest prestigious
academic schools in the country JUCO
kids don't go to those two schools right
so so you're saying that yeah a lot of
the work that you do the show obviously
doesn't reflect that it's just not part
of their story
yeah and that part of the story you know
Tollywood they got to make write ratings
and you know if I'd have known going in
and did some more research because you
know Greg white Lee the producer does a
great job I think he depicts it the way
that I don't think he's out to screw me
or anybody I just think that you could
be the best filmmaker in America and
he's a great one he filmed MIT Romney
for all those year and that documentary
he did and Netflix he has a lot of shows
he omit Romney with the on who did the
yeah the climate change did wasn't Mitt
Romney
no that was a mitten is it first a
mitten I don't I don't even know I don't
even know his [ __ ] ear but now that
was either do Gore when oh yeah yeah I
think that was gorban of those [ __ ]
guys that dick yeah global warming yeah
but Mitt Romney I guess was running for
president or whatever I don't know I
don't know yeah he follow he did his
documentary the same deal you know I
think it looks like you've done a great
job yeah he did a great job filming it I
just don't know if he knows that
complete inside the intricacies that go
into junior college kids the broken home
background the the coaches backgrounds
[ __ ] Muppets yeah coaches too we're
joking and you I think you'd have to be
to spend time around you know to be in
that environment and not get so affected
by it and a lot of people in a year so
your story you or you're from California
right yeah grow up in Compton right and
you played you played quarterback yeah
quarterback whole life yeah and so what
was some of that like growing up like
what was some of like did you have like
a role model kind of in with your folks
around what was your vibe you know I
have my pops and mom around they
divorced I was young and they're both
white yeah both white both white
living with enough chosen leaving my dad
so we went on and all over the place and
California though and then he was a
truck mechanic diesel mechanic and you
know like to drink and come home fall
asleep I mean you know if I why they
divorce
yes but oh yeah you know how that goes
he was a roughneck and so I love diesel
bro yeah that's what he did bad but and
so I had those guys that it wasn't like
I didn't have the support they were
there they were there for me it was just
one of those deals where I was trying on
my own the whole time doing my own thing
man you got to do your own thing yeah so
yeah some of it is you just making your
choices some of those environments make
you become that person product your
environment yeah you know I'm a
chameleon they called me may I can go
into walk into any any type of any home
any background walked out any street in
the country in my opinion and I think
that real recognize is real yeah and
they know I'm not [ __ ] with that guy
yeah yeah you see my god I'm a [ __ ]
somebody with a sword bro yeah I mean
you know I see y'all years ago I used to
I used to look that [ __ ] up did you hope
I look hope somebody looked at I just
said you know I just think that they
knew yeah nowadays you know they still
know but I'm not looking without that
today I would look at you a little
longer you know but you know you guys
grow you got a mature man you know yeah
yeah you gotta be brave I think um you
know I think you gotta be brave in
certain type of environments you know no
doubt no doubt
and I think me you know I live in the
car man for 18 months going what kind of
car was it [ __ ] I don't know any knows
car was oh yeah Oh Camaro or something
dude I got hit up by ants and [ __ ] I
[ __ ] too bad luckily it wasn't back
east where it got cold yeah I don't
think the car had windows but you might
have froze out dude I uh I got hit by a
Trans Am when I was three beautiful - my
mom had a [ __ ] did she yeah this one
was silver do my dad was more excited
about the car bro you know I'm saying my
mom's over there making sure on my desk
you know my dad's asking me I worry got
it oh [ __ ] I had a Buick Riviera 63
Riviera man got ran off the road bison
got chased man and being a knucklehead
man some gangsters was chasing us and we
haven't and we had to get out of there
and got hit by car and ruined at my pop
yes man it was his baby
yeah it happened um the show do you like
after your second season with the show
do you have a different view of
Hollywood coming out of it kind of did
you have a different yeah you know I
didn't know sanneh and watch it I was
like
I'm gonna watch myself and so really no
yeah exactly I have something what's the
first year because you seem like the guy
that will watch you now and now what
happened was they sent us the show early
right before anybody and they're like so
me and my boss watched the first three
episodes I think uh-huh to get ahead of
it
PR wise oh that makes those of town
folks and everybody the haters we knew
how to combat whatever was gonna be
brought our way right and that's why we
watched it a bit but I was even like
cringing in my self skin like I don't
want to watch myself like it's crazy
well what didn't you was there anything
specific you didn't like about yourself
I mean I know what some of that is like
you know but uh but is there anything
specific for you that you kind of I
thought there was a so much [ __ ] left
out that it was just they're they're
they're kind of pegging me out to be
this guy that was result-oriented
so I was just doing everything that
whatever whatever to win at all costs
right and so they I think they put that
out there and then can you do anything
else at that level though no you can't
and that's why like these guys aren't
staying like it did not stay in there
for four years nobody's gonna stay for
it yet but nobody's looking at stay in
the community unless they get arrested
it looks like I get him six months to 18
months max 18 mostly six though because
I got mostly d1 transfers and all I'm
doing him having him six months it sends
him right back the 18-month kids are the
good high school kids that didn't
qualify that I get that's a little bit
different no different
those are a lot those are a lot of those
kids Wendy won a lot of those kids
majority of those kids are the ones who
made it see the show the first or don't
show the thirty-five other guys that
sign d1 dal'rok Abrams at Colorado who
will be addressed DJ Williams who's a
who's a who's a Jim Thorpe Award nominee
this year Wow show him at Utah they
don't see that you don't see how those
guys man because if you see that full
picture it definitely gives a little it
changes really the scope of I think how
people so many guys yeah you know we rea
Buford's at New Mexico State who's at
who was a transfer he was at Minnesota
we brought him in he has some back
background issues that was a BS deal I
had three kids that left Minnesota over
a big-time rape scandal hmm they didn't
do was cold up there you know and that's
a joke yeah that's just so I got I got
getting a little closer okay and I got
him there right and fixed them and got
him recruited and a lot of the ones
wanting to touch that situation and the
title nine deal now they don't want to
touch it
yeah and my reputation though of when I
put my name on a kid those d1 coaches
know this guy he ain't [ __ ] around
you like he used Carla you almost like
you're running a used-car lot no it is
and they know if my word is on it that
I'm it's it's reputable and my kids
gonna do right and they're all thriving
all 35 of those other kids other than
the five they showcase yeah all started
at the d1 so what so why don't they want
to tell me why is it isn't there because
that's like that story is also very
attractive to me it like gives me more
of a full picture of what your of what a
coach is dealing with at that level no
doubt they you know they don't show
things I wish they show the four-year
school comes in they're the Division one
coach tons of them were the most
recruited junior college in the country
they'd come in there and talk to my boss
and say the players have their pants
pulled up I don't hear them saying the
word [ __ ] I don't see him doing these
things they look us in the eye they
shake our hand that isn't bad being
tight at any other JUCO and he goes
those guys line up at practice to shake
our hands and he goes it's taught it's
clearly taught and I wish they would
show the least coach's talking to my
boss about it and showing people that
you know where we were different and
that's the reason those so many guys
went on and those guys are thriving now
at the four year
Rakeem boys at Arkansas yeah he'll be
probably top two or three running backs
picked in the draft he's a dope Walker
nominee so we got kids that are being
Division one nominees for big rewards
you know what I mean yes I mean who
knows he could be a Heisman candidate so
you know go it we got kids all over now
what type of pride you grab me a water -
and now Jason won as well thanks what
type of I mean that must be it must be a
really amazing feeling when you see that
kind of go on like what's that like for
you as somebody that's been a part of
their journey and that's what gets me
off you know I mean when the losses
don't mean diddly [ __ ] to me in junior
college do you know who played for the
national champion from junior college
last year I would say McNeese State and
there would be again no JUCO oh I have
no idea that's exactly so that's my
point nobody knows and cares about
junior college and what they did and you
know the pot the bottom line is it's
about
can i mold this young boy and turn him
into a man so he don't [ __ ] up at the
four-year and those coaches get a
quality kid and products and they're
good community members and all those
type of things that's what makes me
allows me to sleep at night and I've
done that better than by in the country
and those d1 coaches know that's about
that that's what I'm about and that's
why they'll take the risks kid that a
lot of people wouldn't take they'll call
me and say coach how has he been since
he's been with you I know he got kicked
out at Minnesota coach he's been a
stand-up straight shooter you know and
do you shoot those guys straight all the
time you you would you up you know bend
the truth a little bit not never never
because you know I've seen so many guys
on they come to me and they know and
then you know ultimately that's how guys
get jobs but at the end of the day I
didn't need the d1 coach they needed me
the kids I don't need the kids they
needed me and at the end of the day I
held all the cards because I had the
best player in the country and I'm
getting them graduated faster than
anybody in America and you know we got
guys everywhere there we're probably up
10 to 12 guys get drafted next year
after two shows and nobody can say that
and do you get like any type of like any
type of kickback is there anything where
coaches are trying to give you like look
you steer this guy more my way
do you ever it don't happen man that's
you know it never really happen with me
you hear those stories and the blue-chip
movies of the world and the program and
all those movies oh yeah they show that
[ __ ] but you know it's not happening
that I see a lot of you know the coaches
that you have relationships with you you
you know I I try to tell the kid okay
listen don't go be the other guy be the
guy so don't go to Alabama if you're
gonna be fourth string right go to
[ __ ] McNeese State and start and get
film and you still get drafted football
players a saying man be a Sam's is a
great player I think you a McNeese State
and look all those guys went to Troy and
all those guys that are in a in FL so
it's not you don't have to go to those
places every every place has a every kid
has a place I think there's a place for
everyone and I don't know if but our
kids they did go to those places because
we had the best players in the country
so it wasn't easy to play for our guys
we had transfer from San Diego State San
Jose State couple running backs mm-hmm
they didn't even make our redshirt team
and they started at those four those are
d1 they started so that's the difference
yeah yeah so Allah then that it gets the
players that come in that aren't that
great or I mean the level of competition
must be pretty severe then a lot of
times that practice and suffer at the
beginning of season I'll break it down
like this I'll tell you like this
we had 101 kids go D 128 of them mm-hmm
never played it down for me and we had a
we had a D tackle red shirt that signed
with South Carolina so that tells you
the talent so they're going against the
best a line in the country every game as
our scouts are old line guys that sign
division one that didn't never played
for us we're gonna get Emmett Gooden
that's starting at Tennessee yeah
Jermaine Johnson so those guys are good
but they just weren't quite good enough
to play for us and those guys got
scholarships because I pushing them out
because I'm graduating I'm so fast I'm
getting them out so they can go now go
to the 4-year and have four years to
play three instead of having the
redshirt sit around and waste two years
I'm getting them out if I can get them
graduated and they have enough film on
practice til we film everything right
think I practice summer going against
our guys that they get their signing d1
yeah we don't even see that now is there
but how many of the players do you keep
tabs on after is it such like a
is there such a river of players going
by that you're able to really follow up
with many or no I stay in touch with the
man you know I know statistically
speaking I keep track of all those
accolades kind of I know how many kids I
stand on I know how many kids out of
those 222 kids man 126 of them have
earned their bachelor's 26 of them I've
earned their masters those are things I
care about this show makes it look like
half of them came [ __ ] read not they
can't so the truth of matter is those
guys can't read and I try to tell these
people these academic so-called
professors you know I was told that a
kid told a guy told me professor that
independence meant to job I met with the
teachers I told them these are my
expectations my kids are gonna sit in
the [ __ ] front row they're not gonna
have hats and headgear on and I could
play on their cell phone coaches are
going to be walking the class because
they're gonna check every single kid and
so it's an investment so I'm letting you
guys know if anything's different let me
know so I tried to build a relationship
that way so it's a couple weeks into
school
when the teachers are like manis most
engaged everybody ever had a football
program it's unbelievable did it and
then there's this guy in the back on his
phone he's a professor and I go and he
tries to raise his hand I go well first
of all I wouldn't take your hand in my
class cuz you're on your phone so I'm
just I know they don't like me but uh he
goes well coach Emma Gooden can't take
notes you know not to take notes he
won't pass my class I said well [ __ ] do
you think Richard Sherman knew how to
catch a football unless you tell I
taught him so like people don't realize
like you got to teach these dudes so I
told him this is what I told him I said
Emma good and did not turn down Notre
Dame to come to independence I said I
don't think you [ __ ] turn down Notre
Dame either to come de independence to
teach how about we teach these cats and
that's why there's a chapter in my book
called playing the game so I teach these
kids how to play the game because
academic the academic side of this thing
is a game is it and I don't believe this
thing isn't built on intellect man it's
built on and I mean life right I don't
think I think the kids if you're good
community kids good-hearted kid you're
mean right you do well I think it's
built on that and how you treat folks
the teachers are gonna work with you
then you're gonna figure it out yeah you
sit in the front you go see the teachers
in the office hours after hours you you
sit in the front and this will I tell
kids all the time I said you know what
you're gonna you're gonna sit in the
front row and have a relationship with
these teachers dress appropriate sit in
the front
being gates ask a question yeah
everything I've been teaching these guys
since I've been a coach and the guy in
the back on the cell phone and compared
to the guy in the front when they go
talk to the teacher at the end and the
teacher sees you what's one do you
differ between a being a see ya is a
bubble on the teacher has the hit that
man with the pin at the end win yeah and
so a ver he's gonna favor that be over
that C and ran if you're in the back a D
or an F we're gonna get the F so I tried
telling it together play the game play
the game so it's almost a little it's a
little bit of that with everything
everything got I'll play a little bit of
the game not who you know it's what you
know in life yeah yeah it's at Lisa it's
at least a good mix I screwed that up
it's not what you know it's who you know
yeah so that's that's just how it goes
well how [ __ ] lovely screws it up man
do so many people love your personality
man it's uh it's almost like it reminds
me of it's like Barnum & Bailey
kind of like a little bit of like the
guy that runs the circus yeah I know um
but kind of like kind of like a would
like I don't want to say like a wig a
Barnum & Bailey and I sometimes use the
term Wigga in here but um but yeah like
a uh I think about what it is it's
almost like so Michael Rapaport good
friend of mine of course I saw that yeah
I even knew you he uh he said I'm the
most entertaining guy since Sopranos and
so he's like and that's a made-up guy
because you're a real guy and so you
know you know Greg Wylie man he's a
producer he chose us to pick us you know
for whatever reason I didn't know why
and I and I said you know I asked him
one day I said why did you pick me for
your personality right and he goes you
know you're the most unfiltered guy
filmed in 20 years and I said well then
why then towards the is at the towards
the end of the second season they make
it look like that's the reason why they
don't want or why is it just they had to
make a show or do you think they had
something against you now that had none
against me yeah yeah I mean Greg I have
a lot of respect for each other you know
the thing is I asked him I said you know
at the end of the day why did you want
to come here and he goes well this is a
specific story and Bobbie involved
Bobbie Bruce the kid on the show
yeah and Bobby's very you've really get
engaged with him yeah and I you know I
was like a son to me and I said listen
so I bring him in and I'm ripping his
ass and I and in Greg and they go film
them and right afterwards he walks down
you know yeah I'm opening there how do
you handle it
coach Brown how do you stand for this
why are you gonna show up to practice
tomorrow on time huh why do you continue
to show up to everything on time he goes
because coach will gut us if we're not
there he goes yeah but he just called
you a [ __ ]
whatever he goes oh he really he goes my
mom calls me worse than that and and
then he goes will coach Brown called you
this isn't this he goes yeah but he
loves me
yeah so that kind of I think teary-eyed
Greg and I think chose him to stay stick
with me because but I wish that would
have been shown more right now that yeah
they don't throw that as much they don't
show that is like um and that's kind of
like what podcasting is it's like we you
know who people are and then it's not
about everything that they say what's
the most-watched thing on social media
fights
oh yeah fights they don't show the dog
you being walked you know what I mean
so everybody wants to
I don't know smelling them cats but they
got a one cat pushing a muffin across ah
I'm Jim nazy um I saw the other day you
talk about cats fighting now that's when
it really oh yeah rubber meets the road
oh yeah two cats fighting for a scone is
it yeah yeah you know they want that
identification sorry to interrupt the
episode look I've been accused of a lot
of things but I've never been accused of
sock shoe harassment until now how often
do you think about your socks huh be
honest and I know some of you cretins
out there just love to lock yourself in
the back office and smell your own feet
and just hold your toes open and just
get a big front huh for that
hoof smoke you feel me if you're like I
am you probably think about your socks a
lot but I recently discovered socks that
change the way I think about my entire
existence and they are bombas bombas are
socks that I mean they're just so
stylists are so comfortable if you walk
by a flamingo they'll start following
you if you're wearing bombas they love a
fancy sock sometime lightning will even
strike near you because lightning want
to get a look at your feet
bombas are the most comfortable socks in
the history of feet if you go back to
the beginning of feet you'll see that
they're made from super soft natural
cotton and every pair comes with arch
support a seamless toe and a cushioned
footbed that's comfy but not too thick
they know what they're doing they're not
just aimless socks with many colored ins
patterns lengths and styles bombas look
great in the gym at the office and out
on the town ooh who's the guy with all
the flamingos following him bum bazaar
what feat daydream about and for every
bumbles purchase you make bum buzz
donates a pair to someone in need by
your bum bus at bombas B om bas com
slash Theo and get 20% off your first
purchase
that's B om bas dot-com slash th e o for
20% off Bo MBA
dot-com / Theo get the bombas get them
on your feet and watch the flamingoes
flock did you start to become more a
character of character of yourself in
the second season and I don't know if
you cannot become more of a character
yourself I mean I noticed it even on
stage and performing it's like you do a
show and you start to then you start to
watch yourself and then it's like oh
well is this what I you know kind of
what I am NOT like do you mean like if I
was trying to act a little different
well just if you notice at certain times
like okay right now like I'm and they're
filming me and yeah I know they're
filming me now you see on the show I
don't know if they put it in but I'm one
of the episodes I think they talked
about but I've ripped a staff I had to
coach other kids I bring him in rip to
coaching the kids and I was basically
like I don't give a [ __ ] about these
damn cameras and they even get the [ __ ]
out and and I felt though yeah we were
losing and I and you know I think the
kids
I knew that our team had gone Hollywood
it we played 10 games last year we were
better than all 10 teams by far
athletically yeah it wasn't even close
Garden City played for the national
champion last year that's the team house
formerly yet yeah we're beat them 21
nothing and within four minutes like
that's the team we had and it wasn't
even close they played East Mississippi
for the national champion last year and
that just showed you are we lost six
days out the week where every other year
I've coach we've won six days out the
week and if you asked what that means is
my team's usually win six days meaning
we don't still at Walmart we we handle
study hall we kill the weight room we
kill practice we're right we're good in
the community we treat women right we
didn't have that last year I cut 36 kids
fired seven coaches we had such a bad
nucleus of kids and coaches that wanted
to be on camera right so you get a lot
yeah you get a lot of people want to be
holla we had 200 kids show up that we
didn't know who the hell they were no
and prior engagement and they get there
and we find out oh [ __ ] cuz the cameras
yeah
and we just drove from New York you
better [ __ ] drive your ass back you're
not coming here
well they enrolled in classes
unbeknownst to us prior to them arriving
so the schools there thrive on they need
ft what's his full-time enrollment right
they need that so
survive so they're loving it they're
loving the enrollment and they think oh
the show is gonna bring these kids well
guess what those kids were [ __ ]
cancerous to [ __ ] cuz they were horrible
they didn't belong there player or
person they didn't care this one to be
on camera and so they're in the dorm
with our kids cuz we all live on campus
those kids so they're in there just
cancer in them up and you know it takes
one bad apple to ruin a bunch oh yeah so
that's what happened this year and so
you telling me that's what people do
these naysayers you have to cut you off
Oh coach can't coach this year well I
just [ __ ] forgotten all of a sudden
had a coach nine and two two two and
eight I mean okay I forgot to coach
talent wasn't much different well why
weren't you get in help like if there's
stuff like that going on like that
there's such a larger element that
that's I mean it's something no other
coaches are gonna have to deal with
because you have the cameras in because
you have this attention no spotlight and
then the first year though we had
coaches that were a couple more guys
that were at Division one programs that
were coaching with us for year another
back at D ones those guys were holding
them to the fire a little more and they
did what we that the one tongue language
that I call it we all had this one
tongue language in the program it's it's
it's our way you're going to do it or
not
this past year though we had coaches
that wanted to be the kids friends and
that type of [ __ ] right and I don't I
don't work we're not there boy we don't
go to the club with these kids it's not
our buddies this is we're trying to
mentor you and boot person and mold you
into something bigger yeah and these
coaches we had in weren't ready for that
yes it seems so remedial there I mean
it's like is the it shows that there's
not much for the kids to do is there
really not much for to be done in that
area I mean it's very nothing there's
not a closer Starbucks is about an hour
you got Tulsa Oklahoma which is about an
hour ten minutes north yeah I was just
there a couple weeks ago we're doing
some shows yeah and loony-bin know
Cain's Ballroom okay yeah we'd like
Tulsa manna hang out there it tells us
nice I like Tulsa
beautiful can't drive around everything
smokin under construction but yeah what
are they doing I don't know it's been
that way since I've been there but I
liked awesome in the Tulsa love me man
the people there they could cry late
everywhere I go in Tulsa man they love
me and it was a good it was a good deal
would you go out there to meet lady
sometimes you don't see with the ladies
I mean they got that lady Tammy I think
is her name my boss
yeah you guys ever have any no hell no
no hell no come on man she was like I'm
she's like a father figure and a mother
figure all in one man she was at K State
Hall of Fame basketball player was she
really and she's Olympian so she's big
deal man she's in the rafters at k-state
look nah man everything everybody's boss
everybody thought that though everybody
would walk around that town that town's
9,000 people and there's not a nothing's
open past 8 o'clock at night yeah [ __ ]
it's it's unbelievable there's nothing
there to eat you know I mean it's just
it's one of those places and she me and
her we're always seen because we got to
[ __ ] off campus to deal with other [ __ ]
yeah and everybody oh they're [ __ ]
around and now I [ __ ] you guys
don't get it I never mix business with
pleasure first of all but dude what I'm
saying that you hang out at the salon
you gonna get a haircut you know what
I'm saying
I hear ya see you got the Joe Dirt a lot
hey bro I had got you up man you gotta
get one - I got a barber man [ __ ] I got
a barber man I you gotta you gotta go
low brother I can see her ideas dog that
[ __ ] is [ __ ] uh-huh hey is what it is
man but in the second season did you
start W I know you cuz you started to
get a lot of fanfare are you coaching
right now no no no I'm just chillin I
bought a house and I in an empire mm-hmm
and a brand new home from grad scratch
got to pick the flooring the dead whole
deal and and then that's it man I got
the book tour coming up I'm gonna go do
you know I've been speaking at some high
schools that's gonna start jumping off
and then start speaking around the
country and stuff like that and doing
the speaking engagement deals and and
that's about it man figuring out what I
want to do I don't know if I want to
talk some more really know if these kids
can handle me anymore these enabled kids
that these parents allowed to be enabled
I don't think the kids have changed the
parents have changed over our time over
the years and what do you mean by that
when you say that when we grew up man
there was no second guessing a coach
everything was yes coach yes coach this
and that now these [ __ ] all think
they know everything no no I'm gonna do
this no you're not [ __ ] not
under my watch but that's kind of what
but then if you say that then it's
suddenly like
and now you nightmare parents they call
them yeah but you know it's uh I don't
know man maybe you know all good things
come to an end I don't know if I'm meant
to do this anymore so it's full circle
when I started playing I've made it
professionally I got cut by the chief
got cutting in and fill your plate Arena
League and what year was that uh shoot
Oh
203 both years of those years and so
think who else was quarterbacking around
then where at anywhere everybody the guy
at the Chiefs was Trent Green hurt
Warner was still playing Rams ya know
everybody was playing in was that Renton
did Lorenzen play back then are you
remember that Jerry Lorenz yeah you know
he was at a Valdosta State man when I
was in playing I played Division two as
well so we both were Division two oh wow
and we were battling for the Harlan Hill
award which is a d2 Heisman really
that's Wow yeah he was at Valdosta
played for a coach named Hal mumme
yeah mommy don't went down in
southeastern and who's a big-time
Michael eaves he basically hired Mike
Leach said if you don't know but how
mummy my cleats coached for how mummy
originally back in the day they're kind
of the inventors of the spread open up
offense you know I mean but he was at
Valdosta man and I guess he now we
didn't play against each other but uh
but everybody knew who he was because he
was like 400 pounds at quarterback oh
yeah
unfortunately passed away man rest in
peace but yeah yeah he was I went into
Lexington a couple times and he would
always pop out and say hey you know did
you yeah he was always a really really I
heard that kind kind of Internet yeah I
was just trying to think of what other
quarterbacks played around then yeah it
was a lot man they're all they're all
still still around a lot of big-name
guys Favre's and all them guys yeah we
used to go to forest town and eat
mushrooms new back and kill
Mississippi's all right we go put
jerseys on me and a bunch of [ __ ]
mushrooms there Brady was just getting
going you know I mean yeah Drew Bledsoe
it's just giving it up and Brady was
taking over and they're starting to win
Super Bowls already you know we're the
same age so you know he's a Northern
California guy do you ever play against
him no no not not nothing but you every
season game you did mm-hm who won we
actually want but I didn't play at the
same time as he did you know he's
started I was a [ __ ] practice squad
guy you had something to do with it I
bet yeah so you know it was good he was
good times you know do you ever play
against any real heaters out there
now you know remember Julie's peppers
yeah so he played for North Kerala for
Carolina North Carolina and Carolina
Panthers he lit me up in a preseason
game he should have [ __ ] been in when
I was in [ __ ] 30 no line you know I
mean but uh you know it is what it is
and make none of it your fault yeah
that's how it is no that's the best is
part of a head coaches job to make it
not their fault no matter what now I
take responsibility ma'am I tell
everybody man the kids and the coaches
are responsible but I'm accountable
there's a huge difference and I'm
accountable for the entire gamut you
know 30 administrative people trainers
coaches football races people and then I
got 200 kids you know what I mean so
which are all like my kids so I'm
accountable man and if people people
don't realize but people asked like okay
Joe Paterno didn't know [ __ ]
you're the head coach you know every
[ __ ] thing right so you have to know
everything I know everything it seems
like yeah you're sometimes it's like or
just from the show's perception it's
like yeah you're always in everybody's
ass it seems like right and that's
because I guess you have to be you have
to know what's going on if you're gonna
be the one who has to be accounted my
thing was I don't want to get a call
from the cops and you didn't tell me
first coach assistant coach I should
know every [ __ ] thing before it
happens because you guys are in the
dorms you know what's going on in your
fury if you have any relationship with
your players you know exactly where the
[ __ ] are and that's how I was
as an assistant my kids didn't weren't
getting in trouble and as a head coach
our number one job of an assistant coach
is to protect the head coach one the
second most important thing is don't let
[ __ ] get put on the head coach's desk
and those are two things that I never
allowed as assistant and I just and I
try to teach those assistants if you
want to get a big time job just what you
got to do and it comes off okay if I'm
hate me now love me later when I get you
the job because at the end of the day
man you know it's a results-oriented
business and that's what's in that book
and you win the game or you lose it man
there's no gray area in football last
time I checked they [ __ ] check score
yeah
and the kids graduated they don't they
get a scholarship or they don't those
things come on me and last I checked
assistant coach doesn't have a win-loss
next to the record on your resume so do
you think you played the game of get it
sounds if you played the game of getting
kids to the next level you know pretty
well Yeah right it sounds like that game
you play pretty well if you you know if
you look back on your years if and even
if you look back on the show I mean even
though it's kind of like a that's kind
of a selective interpretation what do
you think you could have done better or
differently or you know [ __ ] man there
has to be something man there's a lot of
stuff man probably little things you
know I would love to have hired two
offensive coordinator right did you say
yeah yeah we didn't have the money so it
was like it wasn't in my hands to do and
did you take a bigger salary was a
reason you guys didn't have the money
like what there have been no I got
raises here and there and I got up there
you know pretty pretty high and it was
decent stuff for me but I got my off as
a line coach really high my D
coordinator really hide the ones on the
show great arms is he a neat guy yeah
I've known his older brother for a long
time
Martin yeah but you know his wife I
guess tried to bash me which comes off
pretty [ __ ] unappreciative but yeah
they're at a degree for free but [ __ ] me
right so and also I didn't hold him guys
hostage by any [ __ ] they had a plenty
of opportunity to go get apartment and
found ya and made enough coin yeah
but they chose to do that but I guess
the show shows him like I'm the [ __ ]
devil and I kept him there or something
but but I knew his older brother for a
long time and you know they should talk
about me firing him and all that I did
fire him but nobody knows why because
they didn't know what he did and he
admitted what he did and and I hired him
back cuz I love the kid I know his older
brother yeah you know we kind of grew
he's from Pasadena JUCO guys and and so
you know I just came out from his wife
kind of unappreciative in my opinion
what we did for him yes he was like the
second or third highest paid d
coordinator in our league he could have
went out and got an apartment but uh I
don't show those things you know so that
do you feel unappreciated uh-huh
I'm not gonna cry over spilled milk no I
mean I will dude it look but I've got a
couple telling this podcast but
look I'm not gonna man you know the town
would you know who were independence
Kansas was if the [ __ ] show didn't
come there now nobody would and and you
wouldn't know any of those kids and
probably seventeen coaches don't be old
Division one and it probably is in three
million dollars brought into that town
because of Netflix and yeah so I guess
in that regard yeah we got a question
that came in right here from because we
have video came in let's see yeah yeah
yeah this one's related to about the
town's attitude and that's not me a new
disguise even though me and I got a very
similar nose gang gang gang coach Brown
just wondering how did the people in
Independence Candace Kansas treat you do
you think that they were racist not
towards you obviously but I feel like
they didn't like the football team do
you think that any of that had to do
with race thanks gang gang gang was like
I still have a bulldozer yeah I didn't
feel that at all I didn't feel like
there was any racial tension really I
think there's might have been some
undertones there might have been some
underlying stuff I mean yeah that are
using the history book so I think that's
I don't say any we didn't face any the
the town people that I'm that I we I
love the people that there's the hatred
that I took from there there's a select
few guys and most people there love me
and we and we had we got along great man
it was great people there there's these
pseudo guys that make these pseudo names
up so Freddy's really Johnny and Freddie
and Bobby yeah and he comes up with
three names and he's a now from Arizona
but he's right there right and he makes
up these names so the percentage goes up
and hate right and especially if the
other ones talking more than it looks
like it's 50% he's definitely in yeah
and it was that way but you know this is
the thing that answer his question so
you know the Jayhawk Conference in
Kansas and the Mississippi League were
you kind of from Mississippi only has
eight out of Staters allowed but
Mississippi's more prominent black state
yeah yeah cans probably white state yeah
we only had twenty out of Staters
allowed when I got the job that rule
change similar seemingly overnight so we
became an unlimited out of state state
I'm jr. so you bring in as many as you
want it so of course nobody's gonna
recruit Kansas no more because Kansas
high school football is not very good
not to bash them but they don't have the
legislature in place to allow those kids
to thrive they don't Sooners
season's over you cannot have a football
out again you go right into wrestling
track basketball we're in California
Georgia Florida Texas football season
ends after Christmas you can pick up a
football again and your football
training again 24/7 I say everybody is a
lot more trained lot more acclimated
that's a hassle a high school level yeah
so Kansas behind the times in that
regard so I was hoping the out-of-state
rule optimally speaking changed entire
legislature from the high schools it
hasn't yet hopefully it will well but
then it keeps probably keeps movement
sports like wrestling and stuff big in
those it does it does but to answer his
question I think there's some hidden
racial agendas because of the fact okay
now we were Kansas predominant Kansas
eight-team League and now it's we come
out of state our Kansans aren't playing
anymore I say and now there's there was
some you know they were spied I think
and some hatred but we didn't really see
it my coaches didn't really see it yeah
but not from the local people that you
feel like we didn't have that feel there
was no tension that way you think there
might be some underlying stuff it's like
these yeah because it's like they almost
might need to make some legislation to
even just keep white people in sports at
some point no doubt you know and builder
yeah but you know they they come to me
and talk about I think they were more
took it out on me like let's get this
[ __ ] out of here so these [ __ ] no I
said these freaks and nature's won't be
here no more we can go back to having
you know [ __ ] John Deere here well
they must have been upset though the
townspeople were they upset about the
show cuz I could see if it brings in a
lot of knuckleheads like you're saying
into this campus that you don't even see
on the show that are just making a
community hopeful football players like
guys who got you know locked down in D
seven you know her homeschool football
team you know yeah you know they because
they're just milling around town that I
mean was a lot of people's milling
around town probably but you know that's
why I always had a relationship with
every manager that owned a place in that
town Walmart you know all the
restaurants so if any football player
which is going to be a black kid in
there in their mind so that's why I
taught go to the corner store and buy a
black and milds
right and if the 35 year old black guys
in the stores guess who [ __ ] did it
football player that's the [ __ ]
that's the we get that black eye
unfortunately and I taught those kids
man they don't get
[ __ ] about you so don't get caught up
don't be stupid don't be in the store
don't go to Walmart and steal and that
was big before I got the job we didn't
have that issue I never had a kid
arrested and never had any domestic
violence charge we never had any issues
and I let those managers know they'd
call me if there was any concern or
people disrespectful I didn't allow that
[ __ ] and I'd cut him quick so the town
folks knew that discipline was there
before that was since I was there they
know it was tenfold from when I was
there they were robbing and pillaging
before he got there and he felt like he
definitely really tightened a lot we
tighten it up and they weren't gonna
they were gonna free-for-all run around
that town and you cut the kids cut him
what would you do them out of there oh
yeah we cut hundreds is you're fine to
cut him sometimes
oh yeah it's fine we cut them [ __ ]
yeah trim the trim the fat yeah the fat
the cancer my dad died he cancer man I
told him I said [ __ ] I'm not gonna have
that [ __ ] around you better get the [ __ ]
you better shit-or-get-off-the-pot
yeah so you getting lonesome in the town
yeah you know us man we work 20 hours a
day people don't realize we worked we
were there you know burning midnight oil
man and we were tough we had we had way
to five I mean my staff was there for to
get the damn thing ready and and really
were you there - were just the staffs
there you get to show up now later I
show up a little later for the fact that
I did all that [ __ ] for 20 years right
now I get bills and all that it's their
time to [ __ ] figure it out and
they're gonna get fired and that's just
a results-oriented
but I also did everything else like I
was there I'm my thing is if you're
going to be a leader you're going to
show it you're not talking so everything
that we did I did obviously but certain
things like that
I believe head coaches bit they've
earned the right to sleep in the next
four 20 minutes oh yeah but you know
those things those those type of things
happen and and then we were there till
midnight man and we were few checking
them at 11:30 p.m. getting right back
over four so I mean you know we're there
all day with them class checking them
dorm checking to make sure they're not
smoking and stealing and doing any
stupid things and and unfortunately last
year we had more of that than any any
year I've ever been as a coach and well
it seemed like you said like you know
you had kind of control over that then
what made it go so haywire last year
the cameras really yeah its nucleus bad
nucleus and did it do you feel like you
could going back in it would you have
done anything different to like from the
top down like this is how it is know
what I don't know I think it might have
been inevitable man I don't know if he
could have changed that I don't know if
anybody could have came in there and did
anything different I was gonna change up
anything because my models always been
successful so why would it change all
the sudden which Delayer day I don't
think I change I think because the egos
dangerous man I noticed from own ego you
know like my career's changed a lot of
work for fifteen years and in the past
year it's really gotten a lot different
yeah you know and sometimes it's tough
for me you know I'm tough some dubbing
we've gone through stuff here with
working with my producer it's been tough
for me to learn to work with others but
it's been tough for me to learn Who I am
as I'm becoming more of a I have to be
more responsible and stuff you know it's
well grow yeah and then it's been tough
for me I've had a lot of struggles with
it yeah and sometimes it's my own ego
sometimes it's in insecurity you know
it's a little bit of everything
you know I think football coaches
especially head coaches are probably the
most egotistical humans on earth I think
football players are the most
egotistical people on earth and I think
that's where you get the head-butted
head butting going on but I don't think
I changed I think as the year went on
you can see my boss made a comment the
other day you can see in the show
because she watched it you could see on
the show how you just relax
give me the [ __ ] over this year because
you didn't want to be around those kids
those coaches nothing and and I didn't
and that's why when I was without week
five to be honest with you I was
thinking about what I'm doing different
next year already saying I already had
the plan I was doing it every night to
midnight or 2:00 in the morning 3:00 in
the morning in my office building this
year's team and is that because if if
you don't win that year if you don't get
to that hot like if you're not
undefeated then it doesn't really matter
or what is not just that I knew this I
knew that cutting the NIT in the nucleus
we had and it was just a bad patch man
bad batch from top to bottom and I knew
I was starting over and we're gonna gut
this thing and we were gonna get back to
the basics and character first was what
what I was changing so I had character
first wrapped everywhere on the facility
and that was going to happen and that's
so that kid that German kid that I that
I hired that that whole issue happened
with I hired him to be a graphic design
guy and he was a manager came from in
overseas came out there and I got him a
job on campus and fed him everyday
I said listen if you can help me wrap
this facility get it right nice I'll let
you be on the team you'll never play but
I'll let you be on team and what he was
gonna be on the team a soccer player I
don't know what he would have been but
you know he he he did a good job and I
let him in he helped me wrap that thing
getting all the day's going yeah but I
say it a lot of said look good yeah so
you know that pace was bad when I got
there man it was you don't even know we
built everything with these man and
that's the most rewarding thing I think
the blood sweat and tears you put in and
when you win it and that's the most
rewarding deal in anything but yeah he
counting did he backstab you a little
bit I didn't think it was that bad
texting you called my buddy Hillier I
doesn't mean anything to me it's like I
don't give a [ __ ] it's like it's a joke
between friends and it's a [ __ ] he
called himself that yeah and that's when
he got there he did that and the team
called him that everybody called him
that word yeah digital Hitler I think is
one of his screen names yeah yeah it's
crazy he had he had the bank off book
he'd walk around with it he did it yeah
he did a lot of that it's all gonna come
out man the truth and entertaining is
man he did a lot of that stuff and the
kids were gonna kill a man after the
whole deal and even though I'm getting
investigated I'm having to protect that
kid from getting killed by the players
and people don't know that and you know
I'm at it for it because you because
they were trying to fire me over it oh
yeah wanted you there yeah and they were
like your ass called yourself dead now
you want some 15 minutes of fame right
and he you see in the show I guess Greg
I thought depicted it right you know you
see us there all the kids are calling
him that well I'm calling him at all you
field in the office he's laughing and
giggling because he knew and you see
this text messages that were put in
their their their stuff scratched out
yeah on the media there's some stuff
missing that's unbelievable and how
people take your opinion and run with
their own opinion and run with it
yeah it's a text message between two
people who gives you it if I'd say it's
a NIC and I'm looking I'm sorry if I'm
being a Hitler today or you know let me
ask you this did you know this are my
boss the president of the college mm-hmm
was from Jewish descent who Jara
barnwood bar oh yeah I knew that so he's
up there saying these things in the act
building I get wind of it I bring him in
the office i suspend him he also I had a
huge issue with him in females females
are coming to me left and right like
he's super scary to them yeah
and he's creepy oh no way [ __ ] over
he's hurt a little and I mean and I got
a [ __ ] you feel me
so he's breaking he's breaking into the
weight room man and it sounds like
Selena this totally two forces that
killed Selena I [ __ ] man I'm just
telling you why don't you let that guy
go well I did i suspended the guy and I
cut I said you're done here he
immediately goes from there to the
[ __ ] academic reeling and doing like
the March and [ __ ] and the teachers hit
call me and that's when I send out to
Texas and I was really doing it as a
joke to say listen I'm trying to help
your save your ass but I'm your new boss
basically get your ass over here and see
me because you're not gonna do that [ __ ]
under my watch and in my program and
make us look bad as a football program
did so that's why I regret that I regret
doing that way because obviously
nowadays with the soft natured people
that we live in this culture society
they want to get 15 minutes of fame and
they're gonna blast you out and then I
don't blame the kids man I don't blame
the kid you don't blame him that'll
blame him I blame the cowardly grown
folks I pushed it I get the kid a job on
campus it's the guy that employed him
that pushed this right and it's a giant
it's ridiculous because I'm not the
president not the president because the
president seemed kind of he doesn't
comment on it in the show but yeah I
mean I knew that he was Jewish he seemed
like it you know and then and but then I
was like oh he didn't really comment on
it then and then he you know like I
don't know if anybody because we care
nobody here's the thing nobody really
cares about any of this [ __ ] nobody it's
like people write articles and then
people that are bored if I wasn't a
public figure I'm still there nobody
gives a [ __ ] the thing is the president
winning do you think that anybody would
give in to the thing they had won 30
years
you're one we went in there we beat four
teams that we haven't beaten thirty
years yeah we beat oh they got a picture
of other the independents football team
for like 25 years ago and half of em on
ice skates dude [ __ ] shitty
squad bro well that's what I mean so we
go five and four year what a minute
catcher's mitt on dude and
sit vote five and four year one yeah I
mean unheard of so like okay [ __ ] make
sure we win it like then we did I have
one bad year and that's that's not I
wasn't worried about I was like I'm
never gonna fight for a bad year after
what we've done here in years so that's
why your week five I was prepping for
this year right and I was already
gutting it getting ready for the program
because I think we would wanted all this
year we had a great staff I hired the
best recruiting class in my three years
there so it even been better going that
happens what could you have done
differently you think if you were
looking back on I mean what um man I
don't know man
I don't know it sometimes sometimes
things are supposed to go the way they
go man I don't know if you can change
something you know I didn't do anything
different it was you know the cameras
didn't bother me it was they bothered
other guys but I this is the one thing
I'll tell you which might sound like
jokingly as a joke
I'll never hire these young [ __ ]
coaches again so maybe I'll have a staff
of [ __ ] eight-year-olds next time I
get a job because those guys know the
the intimate setting of the locker room
and when we grew up in football football
locker room was the most intimate
setting period now it's a mockery it's a
place where kids want to film you
cussing out the team because Johnny
stole at Walmart you cussing out the guy
and the team for making an example of
everybody so you better not do it or
this guy you're gonna do end up like him
cut or in jail and they want to film you
on the low and right put it on social
media and even coaches
young coaches I'm just like what does
this become everybody's got their clout
and that's what's kind of gave me sour
tasting coaching maybe I don't want to
do this no more if it's become such a
spectacle well there's so many battles
it seems like you have to face not only
trying to keep these I mean you're also
you're at the cert you're like a second
year you know you're at the oh yeah
you're a father but you're also you're
the tenth behind the big circus it's
like this is where - Adam no don't know
they got animals doing cigarettes out
here you know I'm saying half the guy
you know that's where we this is where
all the shit's done and you don't they
don't show it like you know there's a
lot of things and you know you get drug
through the mud back there they just
show the good [ __ ] you know dumping
water on me when we win it all like you
don't know well we had to go through
that thing you know I mean and it's not
like it's a 20 minute ride from in
Californians you call you taking 20
minute bus rides you know we're going to
the Garden City 7 hours across the state
or to Iowa or whatever and you know you
got to deal with those kids and hotels
overnight I know yeah
oh I'm sure especially with social media
now everybody's trying to [ __ ] each
other and all it is it's yeah it's a
it's a joke man it's becoming oh you can
[ __ ] somebody at a truck stop you know
saying if you got a felt if you filling
up a 30-gallon tank you'd have time you
know what I'm saying it's like these
days it's so easy to just cross paths
with someone go to am/pm or whatever
yeah um do you uh do you wish you were
still in independence uh not how it
ended
no because I just don't I feel the court
said ran it's you know the time during
his course I think it was done it was
time to move on all good things come to
an end I built that placement I mean
there's a brand new turf field there
state-of-the-art locker rooms yeah
eating real nice you name it we I did it
and some sort of I missed that part of
it because I know what we were gonna
have it would have been the premier
place in America there's no doubt about
it
but at the same time man if I've never
kissed any one's ass man if you don't
want me there
I'm [ __ ] leaving on my own you don't
got to beg me to leave and you don't
have to force me out I'm leaving on my
own and that's just how I was raised man
and so if you don't want me I don't want
to be here either
and for the most part I was wanted by
everybody you know 99% of that town
wanted me there man I get a lot of love
emails from them people to this day an
independence man and I love my time
there you know to be on a small town and
all that but it was fine with me I was
there to do a job which was to help
young boys turning them in and we did
that too we excelled and we did it
better than anybody in country and so we
put our we put our footprints in the
sand man so to speak and we've said
history made history there and and now
maybe is something it's a new new
venture to have to be had what do you
miss him right now about coaching they
interaction with the kids you know I
mean recruiting and getting those kids
finding the next and be good in or
rocking Boyd or Malik Henry and trying
to save one of them because you can't
save them all so my whole thing is save
one of a man we
as I tried to tell these young coaches
you try to save them all you're gonna
spread yourself too thin and be super
super heartbroken at the end of the day
I learned that as a young coach and did
you yeah and so you know now you just
try to pick one and save that one kid
and hopefully we saved more than that
obviously but that's that's my goal and
so hopefully I missed that part of it
trying to find a guy to save again and
you know help these young cats out some
of these other when teams were playing
you guys in your conferences last season
were a lot of the were people more
trying to beat you or trying to beat
that team me we hated me they hated you
they hated me in California when I was
here because I beat everybody's ass and
outreach everybody that's how God Hey
why do they hate you everywhere you I
mean I love me later man I guess you
know man do you think people love Nick
Saban they play against them you know
what's funny is I hate Nick Saban but I
respect him more than any other coach
that's why I'm saying so those coaches
don't like Nick Saban he runs this
that's his [ __ ] as he sees his league it
ain't
well the holy thing that League it's his
league it's a billion per second Seguin
savings conference you know I mean and
uh and those kids those coaches don't
want that if I'm trying to beat him and
so remember everybody was on the TV show
a national netflix last year so every
team we got whether they were shitty or
good
we got them times ten they were on
steroids yeah and everybody wanted to
beat us on film on camera and now try to
tell our guys man you don't understand
you're playing a team that shitty and
they're rising - they're rising 10 times
over they brought they brought rising
out the toilet right now you wanna beat
your ass man on Netflix and I lose on
Netflix they did last year we beat
everybody on Netflix last year
everybody's pissed we're talking [ __ ]
and was the show coming was the show
gonna come back for a third season
possibly not definitely not definitely I
wasn't told they would but there was
probably a big time chance because I
don't know I've been told I'm not gonna
say her name but I've been told that
they're gonna have a hard time replacing
me on there just because of the
polarization I guess not to boast but I
don't I think they're having a hard time
finding somebody now and then how many
coaches are going to
now that they see that stuff coming out
and how I'm portrayed there's a lot of
these coaches even in those giucose know
me they know that ain't the real me like
they're like [ __ ] you got [ __ ] over
they're not going to probably accept it
too without you're gonna do this to me
you know what I mean right so they
probably had that battle too so it could
have been easier deal just to follow me
and keep [ __ ] me yeah yeah cause it
seemed like they went to seasons and
from what I heard they were gonna they
weren't sure until the last minute if
they were gonna switch to a different
school yeah and then and I've worked in
you know unscripted programming before
and it's like yeah you never really know
until like yeah I mean until a couple
weeks before the camera starts rolling
they can make it a different that's
greenlit and I kind of feel like this
story yet I mean there would have been a
chance for like a comeback season but
after that I couldn't see how they would
go more than and to be honest I didn't
want to in that year on the loot 2 & 8
you know I mean yeah you guys got [ __ ]
and you know we lost four games by won
two games by three like those games we
lost and then we get blown out by the
worst team in the league and that was
because it had hit the nucleus had
settled in and it was like oh [ __ ] we're
done what was wrong with the quarterback
that uh it starts Jay Jones yeah Jay
Jones what was wrong with him was he
just often injured injuries I don't know
how mentally tough he was I think he had
other ulterior motives as far as maybe I
think he was already looking forward to
maybe you know he had girlfriend back
home I think he was home sick I think he
thought it was maybe beneath him he was
a great kid I think great hearted kid
yeh seemed like a good parent good
parents man raised him right I just
think he I think he was there and that's
out of his it was out of his League and
he was just like huh and you know I
brought in some good backup guys
one was a true freshman that was I
didn't want to play this year had to
chase no no I was a kid named AJ right
the third guy oh yeah with the long haul
tall so he's way too much hair on that
kid yeah she's he's a hair to human body
ratio it's a it's not a uni it's a very
unique amount that's what I'll say he he
he he's gonna be special and didn't want
to throw him in the fire like that
so you know the backup comes in that
first game and rips it last for like
three hundred three touchdowns and [ __ ]
so we start in the next game and he
looks like [ __ ] yeah and we're down 35
knot and a half we come back storming
back should've won the game put in AJ he
rips it come back then he gets torn
labrum in practice then check we go back
to chase you come back that all season
you look and then we're back to it then
we were trying to play a fourth-quarter
back so people I realize yeah you to an
82 but so you know we had 22 offensive
line change ups meaning there's so many
injuries we've had to swap left tackle
had to play right Center had to play
guard we had so many injuries why some
injuries just one of those deals one of
the things is we met were the only team
in the league didn't have a turf field
so when I got that done and got that
donated and got that going we were still
practicing the whole entire season on a
basically rock field and we had so you
know we had six ACL blowouts during the
season I practice we just didn't have
the facilities people don't realize
somebody should open up a a CL factor
around the corner dude people they know
what we've dealt with man broken ankles
you don't understand then we get the
turf field for the last game of the
season Knight [ __ ] a little late so
that's why I was looking forward to this
year because we had all the new time he
had to get to play with all the new toys
yeah Malik you guys brought Malik back
in was it just out of necessity really
no it was to save his life
so I brought him back known the kid a
long time since we shared the same
mentor my junior college head coach it
was also his quarterback coach and so
I've known him a long time said little
kid his dad you know he didn't get
anything because of the show probably
the bad light and then we brought him
back and I told him I said listen you'll
be a practice squad quarterback yeah and
I said right now because this wasn't
your team that's not the talent set
that's built around you the first year
his talent was about around him we could
we could play action RPO right hand the
football off but he does throw it's a
great wide receivers he had a best owe
line in the country and this team wasn't
built that way we were going to run more
option with Jay
spread it out be more play faster those
things when you brought him back in what
did you tell him who you reached I told
them after the season start for now beef
you know I was done he
graduated we were trying to get on a
scholarship he had three years to play
Division one so we were trying to get a
market to get him out of there and a lot
of people didn't want to mess with them
so I said listen I told my players and
coaches I said listen he can't come back
and do anything he can't [ __ ] on himself
or he's done he'll never play again he
came back did a great job for us like
practice squad he did a hell of a job at
practice for our defense he did all
those things but so that a necessity had
to play and we were down to nobody and
he ripped it against Garden City and we
should have won the game
probably should have threw the ball
every down he would probably threw 4,000
yards I don't know he's that good yeah
but we the next game we start him we get
blown out because it wasn't him it was
the team and and his attitude went to
[ __ ] then not really it was just a
matter of this isn't this is I've
already losing the team now I'm losing
the team and Malik wasn't here in the
beginning he wasn't here all spring to
battle in the snow and fighting and
retina in weight room and running and
and I just felt it wasn't fair to the
kids and so the truth of the matter is I
cut I told him I said listen man
no hard feelings you know the deal this
ain't for you this ain't your team the
saint this team not built around your
skillset and and I'm losing the team and
he's like coach I get it now that's a
simple conversation he continued to
practice with us and people don't stay
there show really that and and so now
he's starting in Nevada he got named his
starter today nice really yeah Wow mmm
that's pretty Cody feel good about that
yeah he's no he'll rip it man they fill
up all over the place he'll dominate
that league and yeah he'd get drafted if
he's if he's if he's uh he stays of
course now whatever they had another kid
on the show a UH a Adrian no the the kid
he's like he was defensive got number
six Kaylin Davis yeah it seemed like he
couldn't even write or anything
Kaylin man he huge personality yeah
great idea ray this kid yes he a sister
died on them his brother died on him out
during the time at my place and so I
kept him from leaving because I knew if
he went back home he would be yeah we
did nothing good and I said listen man
you're gonna save your mom's life
eventually you have to graduate and get
this done and he struggling class
obviously and
got him graduated man he's at Arkansas
State around and he'll have a chance to
prolong his career and make some money
and maybe help his mom out man they come
from a bad poor background and you could
play Louisiana yeah good player man for
his size he's a tweener and that's why
he probably didn't go big time huh he's
a tweener we don't know if he's an
outside linebacker or a D in yeah great
and how that yeah so Arizona dollar
schools came in on him late and he's
like man I'm will go to Arkansas State
Louisiana Louisiana yep oh wow so is del
we had a lot of Louisiana kids yeah yeah
we got some other video questions that
came in yeah and I had a question about
Malik
dad they interviewed him a lot in season
three well did you have a relationship
with him cuz like to me it seemed like
he just showed up in high school when
Malik started getting some recognition
and like he seemed like a well-spoken
dude but I didn't trust him ya know I've
known him I known him a long time like I
said we share the same mentor me Malik
and uh I've known his dad
Marcel a long time so yeah he was around
he noted me him his mom we got a divorce
I believe and they were kind of back
before so that always makes it tougher
that people don't get to see so they had
their own personal deals that probably
were struggling it was very hard for him
to be around Malik
so I don't know the whole totality that
whole deal of the family wise but now he
came to every game at Independence duel
he flew in every game do a lot of
parents start to mill around whenever
the kids are doing well do you see a lot
of that hurt not of the Howard I can't I
didn't allow it he was a different deal
because he was out come coming from
California and flew in every week you
wouldn't have that from normal parents
coming in every game to a junior college
game it was on YouTube so kids would
watch their parents would watch it from
home or whatever we had so many kids
from so many places yeah but he would
come to every game and you know I let
him be on the sidelines during game not
on the side but back but he was there
and he supported him he's brought a hell
out of him the whole time that he was
there with me and so it was it was a
good deal but now I'm sure he'll be at
Nevada games you seem to like a guy's
has like a chip on his shoulder you know
which i think is I think you like if you
want to be a guy who survives and
achieves and things in this world can
often be great you know I feel like a
lot of my life I've been that way where
do you think some of that comes from for
you you know just being told I couldn't
do it that forever there's nothing
greater present pleasure in life man
than doing something that was told that
you cannot do
you know and that's I wasn't opposed to
take the independent job you can't do
nothing there you never know when they
haven't sent a kid d1 in five years and
then won a game in ten but what about
when you were young I mean now in that
nest him back from you know he's the
only white boy in Compton you know
survive oh yeah those type of a lot of
shot Jeff out dude yeah so you know yeah
you know he's we've been competition
yeah no doubt you'd have to shave your
head though but yeah but you know I had
you know I was raised by a big-time you
know guy in the drug business you know
what I mean and I was raised by guys
like that and street guys and actually
easily been in the dope game but I was
like nah I'm gonna be a leader not a
follower that's my thing teaching these
kids don't don't go left go right at the
stop sign
cuz guys will follow you regardless yeah
and so I preached that so you know I was
like I'm gonna be elite I'm gonna smoke
weed and sell dope I'm gonna I'm gonna
play sports and try to affect some young
men's lives and so that's why I chose to
do back to the to the thought about like
when as the second season I'm going they
gotta have some ladies hitting you up
yeah they did man it was crazy man you
get out the Tulsa meet some ladies when
I I didn't mean any one man I had no
time and I [ __ ] you know gotta make a
little time man you know it it's crazy
people that know coaching you're there
you're there coaching the season
obviously it's 24/7 so does the season
ends man you're taking your staff you're
splitting it up and you're you've
created this recruiting database and
you've created this plan now we're eight
to ten guys on the road from the end of
the season tell Christmas break and so
and we're everywhere in the country and
so [ __ ]
I'm everywhere man just trying to get to
new batch of kids and right hell yeah it
never ends never any human guy would a
couple nuts no no no some point wha yeah
I was flying a man man here and there
there now we're talking not now more I
can't but I did
you know and that my had to be startling
dude because look I've done it bro you
fly somebody and the next thing you know
like dude this one girl I met one time
had a real small head right and you
can't tell him photos and stuff dude I'm
talking about but you couldn't even
legally Bowl with it you know as small
it's too little
holy [ __ ] and you can't tell them photos
and another thing you know with somebody
that got that you know I'm worried her
head might you know something you know
cuz now injuries could happen you can't
do that online [ __ ] man that's just
dangerous dangerous what they call it
catfish oh yeah I just learned what that
[ __ ] was I didn't know what that's it
what yeah hot oven damn father if I did
that and somebody showed up [ __ ] 500
pounds out of oh I would have lost my
[ __ ] or you to put them on the offensive
line yeah they can't move very well you
found a line let's take another call we
had we had so many submissions you got a
question actually have a patreon
question alright from Kyle Savage and he
wants to know I know you just briefly
touched on it but what do you think you
would do if you weren't a coach or
involved in football like what do you
think what would I do
I don't know man [ __ ] you know I'm a
great recruiter and that's what my net I
started my name built on recruiting but
but selling cars and [ __ ] that ain't me
though man even though everybody says
how you could be a tail salesman great
salesman I'd have no oh I I think you're
no I'm just saying you're stable of
players it's like a used-car lot no
doubt no doubt there's nothing people
have told me before like no really far
you can sell ice to an Eskimo man why
don't you just sell cars and I'm like
that ain't my thing probably because
they don't help nobody in my opinion you
know I mean right so you do have a
feeling really that you want to you do
you feel effective when you're able to
help people
oh yeah yeah that's what I would me to
sleep at night man not win the losses
you know I mean nobody gets it and you
know what I've told people cuz the
shoulders yeah I mean I know you you
know you that you haven't seen it but
the show doesn't show that it does this
doesn't have that element of you know I
know you know that's why I'm here it's
got more like this Huey P long kind of
like guy which is an awesome character
man trust me it's also a character I
think we need out in the world that a
character is still allowed to have like
some sort of manly attributes and tell
everybody to go [ __ ] themselves if he
wants to you know quest like that
especially in LA trying to outlaw you
know they're gonna take our balls soon
bro
you know I think there's some great
American words that they didn't like me
to say man I think [ __ ] like
probably the best one oh dude they set
it on some of the boats if you listened
they got some you know transcripts from
the Mayflower a lot of people are like
yeah [ __ ] we going to America
right yeah Columbus huh oh yeah [ __ ] I
don't know man I think there's some
words out there that I think kids
resonate with better yeah they don't I
couldn't you think I could whisper sweet
nothings to bye Bruce son please do
write kidding me mom calls him every
[ __ ] [ __ ] the book so so
like you know the salad they don't
people that much they don't know what
being in my shoes entails they don't
know where these kids came from and what
I had to deal with and those kids don't
know those words and like you said a lot
of them come from their third grade
reading level yeah third grade reading
level man and like I said it ain't built
on insulation if you know how to play
the game you might sign anything for
paycheck regardless 22 my NFL guys
weren't [ __ ] scholars let me just
tell you yeah but they're making million
dollars yeah it's an experience based
life I think we live it's not it's not
built on intellect I think is built on
hands-on experience out there and get
your get your get your hands dirty man
and figure it out and I don't know if a
piece of paper from a college really
means that much
it's definitely any [ __ ] you ain't
making the money back to pay it off you
ain't making more money than the college
degree cost what are you gonna work have
you know what yeah overtime you're gonna
spend ten years you working life paying
it off for sure
biggest scam in the country man but um
but yeah it's interesting cuz at that
level then you're only the only thing
you can do you're not a parent to these
guys I mean you can try to be like you
know you can try to be a shoulder here
and there you can try to be a role model
but this the the scope of time that you
have with them the fact that they know
everybody knows this is just a curve in
the river we're trying to get you back
upstream mm-hmm there's no bones about
any of that is there no not at all I
don't I don't like I said I told people
people are all saying we won the thing
last year yes and everybody I saw in
public not one person said damn coach
you're a hell of a coach you [ __ ] one
did it so everybody this year was like
man you're gonna get bashed for doing
two and eight I said no I'm not nobody
gives a [ __ ] about that watching that
part on the show I have not yet been
told do shitty you into an eight nobody
gives a [ __ ] they're like yeah
[ __ ] we love you yeah and
that's all I'm told
nobody cares about wins and losses in
that [ __ ] people people think that
that's not really what it's about now at
the SEC its wins and losses right NFL
its wins and losses right you're not
molding me your boys in a minute making
them yeah you guys are sous chefs down
you guys like prep not you know your
chefs but you're like prep cooks you're
getting these ingredients ready gotten
them and cutting them and skinning them
and yeah oh that's it
all you guys new hunters [ __ ] do
would you huh would you take would you
take a job at a different level you
think you know I would if it ever was
that it was that time you know I mean
I've had offers way back and I not as a
coach but like an off the field role and
stuff like that I don't know if I regret
it or not maybe it took any sort of
recruiting then yeah see I did that man
III think everybody knows that but
they're scared man you got to understand
I was told by a great man one time like
you know why you won't vote d1 I'm like
what's up
well first you rough around the edges
too what's gonna happen when you leave
independence where they getting the kids
what's gonna happen when you leave
Compton college were they getting the
players from because I had the best
players and so those guys had to get
those guys from somebody so if I was on
their level kids disappear and so never
looked at it that way
and kind of stuck with me and I was like
[ __ ] I'm start charging these [ __ ]
then yeah shut up I would love to see a
TV show of him coaching peewee football
maybe [ __ ] I don't know if I could do it
get to him before they're corrupted and
entitled yeah I hear you but it but [ __ ]
I'd be [ __ ] in jail bro well slap the
parents and everybody [ __ ] oh [ __ ] Umbra
every Rumph administration would have me
in jail the trouble would hire you I
think Bravo well [ __ ] maybe I don't know
I think he's look man I think you do you
need somebody in my corner man you don't
you do great man not to give so I think
you have a lot of people uh uh I think
you have a lot of people in your corner
man I think it's just nice to hear
somebody [ __ ] yell [ __ ] sometimes you
know I appreciate it man I wish that you
put my payroll in if you could go back
knowing everything you know now do you
think you still would have done the show
or
yeah because in my opinion who am i man
to take away young men and platform for
an opportunity from these youngsters so
like the coach the 17 coaches got jobs
you know you wouldn't ever know who
Kaylin Davis is all right or even my two
white [ __ ] kids chance me and carry
buckmaster they highlighted on the show
oh yeah you know they got my tokens in
there oh yeah you know they did that
nobody would know who they are
carry Buckmaster live a harder life than
most [ __ ] any inner-city black kid
I've ever met they came with a big hair
Mara zona yeah yeah so you know I'm from
Nevada I mean so you know he [ __ ]
lived in a car man drove up here with
[ __ ] tuna fish sandwich drove across
this country to independence man and in
his time there he busted his ass for me
and was a very loyal kid and you know he
was an emotional roller coaster man but
they all are and that's my job to try to
mold them and help them and so hopefully
he figures it out and ends up becoming a
you know has a family and does well in
life you know what I mean but but nobody
would know those guys I know bud even
probably 10 of the 17 coaches wouldn't
have got those jobs that they weren't on
the show so I don't regret the show I
just maybe I should've did more research
on how they were going to depict it yeah
but besides that now I you know I got
those guys an opportunity for you know
the rest of their life to be known let's
take his question right here coach Brown
I just wanted to see what your new
painting was on the new caddy lineup we
got the new ct5 we got the new XTS ct5
looks like it's got that supercharged v8
in it so I wanted to know what your
opinion was and what your plan is for
the new year
now Gang Gang Brown crap dang right I
don't know man I'm uh I got the I got
the V sport out there in the parking lot
man I'm a speed guy you know what I mean
so probably this probably the CT he was
talking about I guess so I'm a speed guy
man but I've had two I got the big body
too so I like getting into ville yeah
and lay back give my dad my sunroof and
my dad bought a Cutlass off a couple
brothers that lived down the street from
us when I was old when I was a kid right
and my dad was old when I was 70 when I
was born he was
old man yeah so he would drive us around
town in this and it had these speakers
and it my dad can even [ __ ] here
right so bro we'd be rolling with 22
just listen to NPR Paul Harvey all the
time Oh banging huh yeah [ __ ] bang
and what I met Chinese food in it bro
one of the things is rattled out what
was the Sikh call bet was donks or what
are they called back down there well the
big-ass rims on a [ __ ] cutlass uh I
don't know people was called him I think
spinners 22 is I don't know what people
call him back then now you weren't born
with spinners were around [ __ ] you know
I was before
probably I was like 16 or something
spinners you know the trouble every
Wells when I started those are the how
do you 22 is I think was the only thing
I heard on 39 are you yeah okay you're
young into me some people said me up
maybe all right is that [ __ ] had rims
then not whitewall I remember somebody
will paint the white walls that was it I
mean everybody the only nicest thing
he'd have us was a 5.0 Mustang that was
big time yeah that thing was big brought
convertible it's one do floored at one
time and he's too [ __ ] real pasty
[ __ ] fell right off the back dude
they were sitting on the back like they
were unafraid but there weren't in a
parade yeah it's very like it rolled
right off the bat cherry marks on the
elbows it's like rug burn man um Jason
Brown I'm trying to think of a neat job
that I would like to see you doing man
you might be one of the last ones like
you brah yeah I know that's what I'm
hearing man somebody maybe I don't know
mill see what happens after this man I
mean [ __ ] bestseller book man it's a so
you know like Tony Dungy guy who went on
Twitter and was like basically saying
telling people you know I played for
coaches that didn't coach like coach
Brown and you didn't need to cuss and
stuff oh yeah Tony Jones he seems a
little [ __ ] soft though my rebuttal
is like you weren't in junior college
and those guys weren't coaching junior
college kids so it's a little different
yeah I can only imagine man it's already
easy enough for it's already these
players were already treated like
royalty as some of these universities
they're already given a lot of second
third fourth fifth chances but the moral
of that story I was telling you is that
books the bestseller Tony Dungy isn't
yeah brah suspect it go with that
yeah I'm ahead of Tom Brady to [ __ ]
believe that or not
oh and it sails I don't know if I
believe that yeah
google it really [ __ ] I've just told
about my publisher number-one book I
hope so she ain't lyin I'm fire ass look
I'm ready to read it um they had a coach
that gave you a book at the ego book
read my quote in there man is it from
his no I wrote you a quote in there let
me see I'm paid man the I appreciate the
support of love must respect what you do
Gang Gang my best coach Brown WI n bro
win man you know what that means what's
important now that's my thing a chapter
in there I appreciate this I will coach
Brown thank you so much for being here
with those you anytime and do it again I
really appreciate a minute wish you the
best of luck and uh yeah definitely
appreciate you guys
[Music]
a little time for me to set that parking
brake
myself
[Music]